I regret is not studying abroad in
college the financial part of it as well
as the credit transfers overwhelmed me
so much that I didn't dive deeper into
it the next regret I wanted to join the
Navy Seals but I couldn't swim instead I
joined the Navy during boot camp one of
the seals recruiters came in and said if
anyone wants to join the seals stand up
now and come with me I still regret not
standing up right then and seeing if I
could have done it the next regret I
regret trying so hard to ignore my
culture when I was younger I would get
made fun of for the foods my mom would
pack for me so I tried to be like ooh
who would eat this next regret my first
concert was the Black Eyed Peas and the
Pussycat Dolls were opening up for them
I didn't buy the iconic Pussycat Dolls
hoodie and I really really regret it and
then the last regret my biggest regret
is not taking dance classes at an early
age I feel like it would have helped me
become more confident earlier